parkour it's a discipline that involves
using the human body to traverse through
space while maintaining as much momentum
as possible started in France by some
radical guys in the late 80s it's become
widely known through awesome scenes in
films like district b13 and Skyfall it's
easy to see the appeal of effortlessly
vaulting over urban constructs seeing
the world in a whole new way high sounds
a lot like video games
in their relatively short existence
games have greatly evolved the way
players navigate through the geometry of
the digital worlds the most significant
strides have been directly influenced by
parkour and the vaulting jumping
climbing and steezy tricks that come
with it have pushed traversing game
worlds toward being a thing of beauty
in 2014 shooters like titanfall and
advanced warfare stood out because of
their mobility and it was awesome
so let's salute our French brothers for
trailblazing a movement that has given
us so much let's run down five awesome
parkour games that have led to gamers
expecting fluidity freedom and that
vision is safe qua beauty a movement
that has made player movement in games
all that much better psyche prince of
persia sands of time of course it was
the French Canadians Ubisoft who
popularized wool running in a game with
its 2003 breakout hit Prince of Persia
the sands of time the game was largely a
platformer with the Prince avoiding the
most video game II of foe spikes
utilizing his acrobatic maneuvers it was
a delicious taste of parkour and one
that came with an amazing redo mechanic
in the form of a magic time dagger it
cemented in our mind what a more dynamic
character was capable of in a video game
world and it inspired Ubisoft to take
this freedom of movement into a more
grounded reality open-world pickle cat
Assassin's Creed
the 2007 breakout hit Assassin's Creed
is not only a veritable job creator due
to its annual ization and enormous
development teams but a groundbreaking
game that allowed the player to
basically free run everywhere and climb
anything of course that isn't completely
true but the traversal options and the
style in which all tie air floats
through the world is intoxicating for
better or worse it has completely
influenced how third-person action games
have been designed I've been one yet
some developers have just said wicket
and made their characters fly through
the world using superpowers which I have
to believe is an attempt to outdo the
beauty of movement which we see in
Assassin's Creed it's a shame it's used
mostly for obnoxious chases or rooftop
eavesdropping these days but it had its
effect on the first person's onra as
well and we've been able to vault wall
run slide and kill in supreme style ever
since
parkour plop dying light
yo Tate tell me about spark or dying
light Dynalite actually it's pretty good
it changes the game I guess here it's
like if you get overwhelmed or anything
it's like where can I climb up what
building can I climb up and then you can
easily kind of escape some of the lesser
zombies so I was really bummed at first
that there wasn't any fast travel and I
was like oh man running along the
buildings might be too slow and whatnot
but turns out you know once you start
leveling up and whatnot and then like I
said eventually getting the grappling
hook it actually makes it super fun to
just run along the rooftops and it and
you know you're just climbing where
you're running and you're trying to make
you know the next building or the next
light pole it totally works it's totally
fun and always a good way that get away
from the zombies they're cool do
titanfall
Titan Falls pilot mobility is legendary
for a game whose namesake is a big
lumbering mech the freedom of movement
afforded by a jet pack and some wall
runs was what excited us the most about
this multiplayer game it isn't the first
multiplayer FPS to feature parkour
inspired movement
what's all for one out for brink in
their Smar t system but the map design
and the ability synergy at play and
titanfall is truly amazing to behold and
then we all stop playing I don't know
why really it's kind of a shame and it's
also a shame that the best parkour game
ever
didn't sell more parkour oon Mirror's
Edge
the problem with doing a parkour game
listicle is that Mirror's Edge is so
clearly the best buy such a huge leap it
isn't even fair it holds up incredibly
well on PC to this day and the way that
it weaves its action atmosphere and
movement together is remarkable building
up momentum by nailing rolls slides and
jumps just the right times never gets
old as well as performing disarms
eSports it's not only a love letter to
the urban travel phenomenon of parkour
it's also an amazing video game one
that's getting a follow up which will
hopefully have even better controls and
be even more beautiful freewheeling flow
of parkour and the open-ended
possibilities of game design are a match
made in heaven
these games are our favorites but what
about yours share a gaming parkour
memory in the comments below
then vault out your window tic-tac up
onto the roof and free run your way
across the city GameSpot and its
affiliates do not encourage or condone
the use of stick as parkour moves at any
time and they are not liable for any
grody injuries sustained in the
performance of such feats but send us a
bit
I actually just pulled something right
now I'm good all right
Oh actually I kind of did that was bad
no I'm fine